singapore is
one of the world's biggest oil trading
centers
and henyon is a homegrown oil trader
in singapore xihin lyon has also always
been very secretive
it's helped by its founder okay lim his
son
and his daughter so very little is
actually known about hen
we've also got this fallout from the
singapore oil trader
he learned investigation started in
april after hindeling filed for
bankruptcy protection it was revealed
that lim had asked the company to hide
nearly a billion dollars in losses
from speculating oil futures over the
years
so it all started when we heard that
major banks were pooling financing from
the oil trader in lyon and at first we
were shocked to hear this information
henlong is such a big name in the asian
oil trading industry
and why were the banks unwilling to
finance hen lyon any further
all the answers only came to us much
later
my name is alfred tang i'm a senior
reporter with bloomberg news
i'm serene cheung i'm a reporter at
bloomberg
serene and i and other colleagues in
singapore office
wrote the story about the collapse of
hindiang
one of the biggest independent oil
traders in the world
so henlong is in the business of what we
call
bunkering which is to supply shipping
fuel
to all the vessels that come into the
singapore ports for refueling
it's actually owned and founded by
lim un qm also known as okie lim
oking was born in fujian province of
china
he immigrated to singapore in 1950s
from the associates who've known okay
for decades okie lim was described as a
low-key
humble aggressive oil shaders and
always honest to his origin oakley
likes dining in a singapore-based
chain restaurant which serves his
homeland food
he is also known as a king poker player
[Music]
he started off as a one man one truck
business he would buy fuel
from oil majors parcel it up into
smaller volumes and resell it to taxi
companies
to bus companies as well as to fishing
boats
ok lim's business later developed to
involve a lot more of these tank trucks
and later on it also developed to
include an entire fleet of vessels
that will actually work as an integrated
supply system
to allow him to buy float
and sell fuel to customers around the
region
hyung actually developed alongside the
singapore
oil trading hub and as more and more
boats came to singapore to
dock and refuel helium grew because it
was opportunistically at the right place
at the right time
so differ from stock market trading
where
information are basically available
publicly
oil traders in the world re on the
information
private to a small group and
find the business opportunity our
understanding of ok lin
is that he is a trader with a very big
appetite
for risk he's also one that thrives in
the very opaque
and secretive market of oil trading in
asia
so for example at any one point
in the asian market no one trader would
actually
know exactly how much supply and how
much demand
there is at any given time okay lim
would reach deep into his resources
and leverage on his relationships
with his counterparts to actually figure
out what exactly was happening in the
market
and therefore to make both decisions to
dominate the market
and create a trading position that's
beneficial for himself
once they purchase the enough physical
stockpiles
in the market and create
disruptions in a certain time of period
and a certain area it did squeeze the
market
and push the prices higher in that case
hinglion and okay lim can always sell
the inventories
and sell the products to end users or
another merchants
for perfect this strategy was one of
the source of his success for decade
but not for this time
[Music]
in april of 2020 my colleague and i
had heard that banks were pulling
financing
and credit lines away from hylian and as
we know
financing credit lines and liquidity are
the lifeblood of trading
so we knew that something big was
brewing
but we just didn't know what it was yet
and it was only in the coming
weeks that more information and the
answers were unveiled
covid 19 brought the global economy to a
screeching halt and one industry hit
particularly hard
was oil in the usa the price of oil has
collapsed to a record low as demand
dries up and storage runs out
the price of a barrel of west texas
intermediate which is the benchmark for
us oil
today traded as low as minus 40 dollars
a barrel
it's the first time the price has uh
turned negative in history
according to the documents we've seen
hing young barely
hates the physical stockpiles its
purchases
so all of its physical stockpiles are
purely exposed to the market
fluctuations
because the oil benchmark prices
slumped on coronavirus outbreaks in the
world
the value of physical stockpiles of
hinge reduced
we know from our sources that okay lin
made opposition bets
on the oil prices because he believed
china will soon put the coronavirus in
control
and the demand will recover very quickly
so
okay was right in the first half of his
prediction
china did contain the outbreaks of
kernel virus but what okay lim didn't
see
is the outbreak turn into a pandemic
and create larger demand destruction
and ben starts coming after him
asking him to replay the unpaid debts
dozens of commercial and investment
banks in singapore has a combined
exposure of 3.5 billion us dollars to
hing lyon
of which hsbc had the biggest exposure
of 600 million another banks such as dbs
and ibm had more than 200 million
exposure
to henry
so from speaking to our sources and from
documents that we obtained
we came to realize that hindiang had
actually
not made any profits for a couple of
years
and that some of the oil that henyon had
used for collaterals
were actually already resold to other
customers
it was shocking to see
that the company had actually hit 800
million in losses
the growth model of singapore the south
east asia and china has been changed
through these years and that could be
part of the reason
why xinjiang didn't make any profit
many countries stopped seeking
replacement
of traditional full cell energy
replacing them
with renewable energy such as solar
the coronal coronavirus outbreak is just
the trigger
always collapsed the founder of
homegrown
oil trading firm hindiang trading has
been charged with amendment of forgery
for the purpose of cheating
lim un quinn allegedly asked an employee
to forge
a document to state that kin liang had
transferred more than one
million barrels of gas oil to china
aviation oil corporation
this document was allegedly used to
secure almost 77
million dollars in trade funds from a
financial institution
if found guilty lim could be jailed for
up to 10 years and fined
king liang and lims is one of the most
secretive family business in singapore
multiple attempts
to henyang and ling's family for
comments
went unsuccessful so after the hindiang
episode
when some banks found themselves with
hundreds of millions of dollars of
losses
we're seeing that the oil industry in
asia is going through
somewhat of an evolution where smaller
companies are finding it harder to get
credit lines and financing and even
bigger companies more reputable
companies
are also finding that credit lines are
being shrunken
[Music]
you